you would think that madison cawthorne  would understand the consequences of  irresponsible driving unlicensed driving  all this stuff  he's in a wheelchair because of a car  accident he was involved in when he was  younger  uh in which if i recall correctly his  friend the driver  fell asleep and i'm not even gonna  speculate on what that means  fell asleep can mean a lot of different  things when it comes to traffic  accidents um and he is regularly  speeding crossing the center line  driving with no no valid license guys  come on it's it's the the double  standards and the hypocrisy i know they  don't care about them but at a certain  point it's almost like a skit they're  such uh hypocrites  um no word as to whether he pulled the  do you know who i am sort of game but  this is a guy who regularly you know to  say he's deliberately breaking the law  we would need to know his state of mind  but he's at least at minimum  accidentally breaking it